Transcriber: Baran Ercan
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Bilim ilerledikçe etrafımızdaki
her şeyi daha iyi anladık.
Bununla beraber bilmediklerimizin ne kadar
uçsuz ve bucaksız olduğunu gördük.
Bu kadar bilinmezlik arasında emin
olduğumuz iki şey var.
Bunlardan biri her insanın doğup öldüğü
gibi evrenimizin de doğduğu ve her geçen
saniye ölümüne daha çok yaklaşıyor olması.
Evrenin ölüm süreci gibi insanın ölme
süreci bir dönüşüm gerektirmektedir.
İşte bu kader arkadaşlığımız nedeniyle
ekranda insanları temsilen bebeklik
fotoğrafım ve kozmosu temsilen
bir fotoğraf görüyorsunuz.
Aralarındaki en büyük fark ise
benim doğumumun
evrenin ki kadar şatafatlı olmayışı .
Emin olduğumuz ikinci şey ise...emin
olduğumuz ikinci şey ise her ne kadar
evrenin başlangıcı bir patlamayla
gelmiş olsa da,
sonunun uzun bir süreçle geleceği.Aynı
bizlerin yaşamı gibi.
Kendimizi bir kenara bırakacak olursak
evrenin sonu olacak bu süreç
hakkında neler söyleyebiliriz?
Evrenin sonundan bahsedebilmek için,
içindeki tüm varlıkların yaşamasını
sağlayan yıldızların sonundan
bahsetmemiz gerekir.
Güneşimiz 4,6 milyardır yanmakta
ve tahminen 5 milyar yıl
daha buna devam edecektir.
Ancak yıldızların ölümü, güneşimiz
dahil olmak üzere tüm yıldızların
kaçınılmaz sonudur.
Yıldızların ömürleri büyüklüklerine ve
yakıtları tüketme hızlarına göre değişir.
Bizim güneşimiz ortalama büyüklükte bir
yıldız olup, hidrojen yakıtını çok yavaş
şekilde tüketmekte.
Ancak bu y... bu yakıt tükendiğinde ise
yıldızın çekirdeği bir çökme ile karşı
karşıya kalır.
Bu çökme, yıldızın sıcaklığını arttırır,
dış katmanlarını genişletir ve yakıtını
daha ayrı olan elementlere çevirir.
Bunun sonucunda ise yıldızımız kırmızı
dev bilinen bu yıldız formun...bu
yıldız formuna dönüşür.
Kırmızı dev sürecinden sonra ise yıldızın
katmanlarını git gide atarak yavaş bir
şekilde atarak, çekirdeği çok daha
yoğun olan ″beyaz cüce″ formuna dönüşür.
Ancak beyaz cüce formu nükleer füzyon
sürecini yapamadığı için,
karanlık olan bu evrende
git gide ışığını kaybederek ve
soğuyarak ölüme mahkum kalır.
Tabii ki de yıldızlar farklı boyutlu...
farklı boyutlara ve
farklı kütlelere sahiptir.
İşte bu nedenle onları farklı ölümler ve
farklı ömürler beklemektedir.
Güneşimizden çok daha büyük ve çok daha
parlak olan yıldızlar, ″süpernova
patlaması″ denilen bir patlamayla ölürler.
Bu patlama, evrende görülen en küçük
patlamalardan biridir ve bunun sonucunda
oluşan yıldız kalıntıları nötron
yıldızlarına
ve kara deliklere dönüşebilmektedir.
Aklımızın almayacağı kadar süre sonra
evren sadece kara deliklerin var olduğu
kara delik çağına girecektir.
Bu dönemde şu an nasıl yıldızların
etrafında gezegenler dönüyorsa,
kara deliklerin etrafında da kara delikler
dönecektir ve çok uzun bir süre sonra
bunlar birleşecek ve daha büyük bir
kara delik oluşturacaklardır.
Ve belki de onlarla birleşip
daha da büyük bir tane.
Anlayabileceğiniz üzere evren şu anki
dinamikliğini ve heyecanını o zaman
bile korumakta.
Çok yakın zamana dek bu
evrenin sonu olarak düşünüldü.
Ta ki 1974′te Stephen Hawking’in ortaya
attığı Hawking radyaston teorisine kadar.
Bu teoriye göre, sonsuz olduğu düşünülen
kara deliklerde bir süre sonra ölebilir.
Hawking radyasyon teorisi, kara deliklerin
çok güçlü ve etrafındaki maddeleri çok
güçlü bir şekilde çektiklerini söyler ve
bu kara deliklerin yakınında bir madde ve
antimadde çiftinin oluşabileceğinden
bahseder.
Bu çiftlerden biri kara deliğin içinde,
öbürü ise dışında oluşursa, kara delikten
bir miktar
enerji çıktığı düşünülür ve buna
da Hawking radyasonu denilir.
Hawking radyasyonu, kara deliklerin
dönmenin açısını azalttığını, kütlesini
azalttığını ve en sonunda ise onu
buharlaştırdığını söyler.
Kara deliklerinde sonunun bulunmasından
sonra, evren bir hiçliğe dönüşecektir
ve sonsuz bir sessizliğe bürünecektir.
Fakat bu durumda bile genişlemesini
getirmeyecektir.
Ben sunumumu hazırlarken aklıma
bu üç soru çok fazla takıldı.
Evren neden genişlemekte?
Ve asıl kafamı karıştıran ise evren neden
hızını arttırarak genişliyor?
Buna ne sebep oluyor?
Siz de sorduğum üç sorunun cevabı ise
karanlık enerjiyle açıklanmakta.
Karanlık enerji, evrenin sonu hakkında
bildiklerimiz arasındaki en büyük sır ve
belki de en önemli oyuncu.
Çünkü; onun varlığı evrenimizin sonunu
çok farklı sonları sürüklemekte.
Mesela bir senaryoya göre eğer karanlık
enerji etkisini kaybedecek olursa,
evrenimiz genişlemeyi durdurur ve bir
noktada durur, genişlemesi biterse,
içindeki maddeler son bir patlamayla
ölecek ve evren...evren diye bir şey
kalmayacak özetle.
Öbür senaryoya göre, karanlık enerji şu an
olduğu gibi etkisini arttırmaya
devam edecek,
evren artan bir hızla genişleyecek.
Bu durumda yıldızlar ölecek.
Kara delikler buharlaşacak vesaire
evrenimiz hiçlikten...hiçlik,hiçlik olacak
özetle.Sadece mutlak sıfırda
genişleyen bir hiçlik olacak.
Fakat bu dönemden sonra ise şunu
anlayabiliriz ki; evrenin başından beri
zamanın anlamı hiç bu kadar
anlamsız olmayacak.
Hiçbir şey olmuyor, olmamaya da
devam edecek.
Sonsuza dek.Özetle; yıldızlar söner,
kara delikler buharlaşır
ve hiçbir şey kalmaz.
Sonsuz bir sessizliğe bürünür evren.
Fakat bu kadar her şeyin sonlu olduğundan
bahsetme...bahsetmek,
bizi karamsarlığa mı itmeli?
Bence hayır.
Sonuçta her ne kadar bir filmin biteceğini
bile bile onu izliyorsak ya da en
sevdiğimiz dondurmanın biteceğini
bilmemize rağmen onun zevkle tadına
bakıyorsak, yaşamımızdaki her anında
değerini öyle bilmeli ve ona en iyi
şekilde geçinebilmek için elimizden
geleni yapmalıyız.
Bu sonu olan evrende büyük ve
önemli etkiler bırakmak için
her an çabalamalıyız.
Hepinize dolu dolu yaşayabileceğiniz
ömürler dileği ile.
Teşekkürler.